when I was about 19 1983 around there
one of my buddies uh dad was [ __ ] up
he was like a degenerate gambler type
drunk type and he I guess his father had
gone to Atlantic City and came back out
off the bus in Union City and he went
into the [ __ ] bus station of the cab
place complaining talking [ __ ] and they
threw him out they spit slapped him or
whatever so my friend it was a
sweetheart of a guy came to the bar we
were hanging out he goes guys I'm gonna
pinch my father got beat up I want to go
down and avenge his [ __ ] beatin get in
the [ __ ] car and I buy drinks later
he was like a bartender so he was gonna
take care of us so myself
ferny Pelican like two carloads of
people go down we pull up and he gets
our first nice or the orchestrator he's
the Steven Seagal I just came down here
to have backup I'm going in there first
because I'm going in there give me the
[ __ ] bat so he takes a bat now this
place the the desks of the cab company
and all this [ __ ] I guess it was a cab
company that the guy bit slapped him was
facing the Sun so they would put like a
sheet on the window and the glass so you
really couldn't see inside what was
going on it was like tinted windows we
could tell it there was people in there
so my friend John take stab at me
he knows I'll be back and he walks in
and we could see that he goes in and he
swings the bat one time and the guy
smacks him takes the bathroom and hits
him on the head with the [ __ ] his the
guy comes out holding his head you know
and then we are like half laughing [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] happened and my buddy
asked me goes what happened to you who
are you Mickey Mantle because he was
holding onto his hand anyway I thought
it was funny when it happened was 30
years ago gives a [ __ ]
greetings on podcast Ville you bad
[ __ ] the Church of what's
happened now is brought to you by
stamps.com time is money baby stop
wasting your precious time going to the
post office when you can send letters
and packages right from your desk or
your home
you could do that today with stamps.com
we've been using stamps.com now for
about six years to send our patches
t-shirts all that mugs and it works
great plus no no lines no nothing like
that you put it on your computer you get
the scale bad but hits you with a
postage stamp you pull outside the
mailman comes and gets it I use them
because it saves my wife and me time and
money and then money is precious right
now they got a special offer for the
church family or four-week trial plus
postage and a digital scale go to stamps
calm and click the microphone at the top
of the homepage and use promo code
church that stamps calm and to church CH
you are CH and start sending mail like a
doctor with stamps calm the church is
also brought to you by zip recruiter
listen you know harley's to chat you
know how hard it is to hire the right
person for your company whether it be
big a large so small it's hard the zip
recruiter makes it easy okay hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
can go we're hiring a simple fast and
smart a place where grown businesses
connected to qualified candidates that
place is zip recruit accom zip recruiter
is the goods they send your job to over
a hundred of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find the right people for you right now
the church family can try zip recruiter
for free it's Monday free at this
address zip recruiter comm slash Church
si-hu rc8 set zip recruiter dot-com
slash Church the smarter way to hire Lee
kick this [ __ ] meal it's a
beautiful day to be alive WK i got you
in studio you look good you look healthy
you look beautiful thank you and that's
it
what's happening yeah crash man we just
locked but two years ago yeah it was two
years yesterday yeah I seen somebody
pull it up that's why I was like we're
gonna you know flew Seattle yeah you
know before you came down here I did no
[ __ ]
yeah and then his he was Susan silver
was pregnant with but Lily when my Susan
was pregnant with May so they we had to
pregnant you know wives together and and
had little babies so his oldest daughter
is Susan's yeah Lily is 18 the one he
was bringing on stage and singing with
her and saying I that's his second
oldest daughter no [ __ ] yeah so you knew
those guys that was he really a cook at
one of those places herself Sam change
that
Roy's bait house it's actually raised
boathouse raised bold and color yeah
Royce bait and then there was what was
the other one that just sold Sam and
[ __ ] like that
Ivers Ivers yeah I was just killer yeah
I mean that's how you like if you were a
punk rock kid or whatever in Seattle you
did construction and you were cook you
were in the back so he started as a
dishwasher because we had blue hair we
had whatever we weren't presentable to
the be a waiter a busboy you had to work
back pan the line and so all of us
probably are great cooks to this day you
know and you knew him you knew the guys
from Alice in Chains gym guys
Alice chase guys I met later cuz they
were down in Tacoma
mainly like when they were starting up I
left in 84
I'd heard about Allison change starting
up I did meet them when I moved to LA in
84 and when those bass started to get
big Pearl Jam Alice Soundgarden I was
like the Seattle welcoming committee you
know so the first time Alice came and
played in LA I play at godless agent
played well then they came to my house
afterwards for like three days Pearl Jam
guys as well so I knew yeah of course I
I mean Seattle you've lived in Seattle
yes and and you lived there back in the
90s it was very kind of provincial you
know very close-knit music community it
was that way in the 80s in Seattle was
kind of way off the beaten track
especially in the eighties you know
before the internet and all of that punk
bands would come through Black Flag came
to do a of course from Vancouver BC but
we were way up there and people thought
we lived in teepees and you know
whatever in the eighties and that made
this really close-knit music community
we were always sharing ideas and sharing
equipment and garages to rehearse in
their basements or whatever and you know
it rains there so you spend your time in
basements honing your craft and creating
weird music that you know the rent no
it's the rest of the countries into DC
had their scene with Minor Threat in Bad
Brains la had their scene San Francisco
had their scene Seattle had his scene
but nobody else knew about it until it
kind of broke in 88 not even know
Seattle existed the SuperSonics playoffs
in like 79 when I was a young I was
there I went to one game with that Jack
Sikma
Jack Sikma just going in the Hall of
Fame my favorite player was downtown
Freddie [ __ ] brown come on drinking a
brown bag at the end of the bench he
[ __ ] what the coach would put him in
like Freddie brown with down 8 go do
your thing
he was built chubby 5 foot like 9
they've had him at 6 1 I was alive Dan
it was like 5 foot 9 yeah my Dennis
Johnson Dennis Johnson you had the
wizard his brother Gus Williams no man
Oh Ray William was his brother he was
playing in New York Seattle when I was a
kid that's how I first got attention to
Seattle yeah yeah I was like that that
place is [ __ ] nuts and I'd watch
downtown Freddie Brannon who did they
lost to the bullets no we want do you
beat the bullets that's what it was okay
we might have lost a year before okay
some thought we wondered that was our
only championship until the Seahawks won
the Super Bowl that was our only like
Seattle championship was the 79
superstar is in that Stadium the
Seahawks like the loudest Stadium in the
NFL or something they're kind of
designed it Seattle is loud do you know
like rock concerts and everything it's
always been like this and I think that's
built out of like because we are so far
up there that we wanted to make sure
like bands knew that we appreciated them
and the same as is
with like sports like the Sonic's games
or the loudest and then they kind of
took this loudness of Seattle and
constructed this football stadium where
the seats come doesn't make good radio
but I'm making Abby's a steep v-shape it
just comes straight down to the field so
it feels like the fans are on top of you
and and it's sonically super loud
it was weird because that will brought
my attention to Seattle I liked how they
played basketball so I'm like I'm gonna
have to go up there mm-hmm I have to go
up there just cuz of the basketball good
team in 95 Oh kid now I'm a [ __ ] kid
you know I'm uh 13 12 when they first
went 77 down where it's a men's yeah
we're opening you saw him being a kid
playing basketball I would write down
Gus Williams just move and go to the
basketball court I [ __ ] you know there
was no Cameron those days on your phone
and playing right down the moon
I'd write down the move oh I'd watch
amazing and I put like a number to it
the whole thing and then I looked at
when I got into comedy in 91 the best
logo in comedy was Seattle like somebody
had put may put time into this [ __ ]
logo and it's like the towers the twin
there's something dug the sky whatever
the [ __ ] it is specially the Space
Needle it was like a face on top of the
needle and they bent over I'm like you
know what man I've always wanted to go
to see how this will be it for comedy
and then bubble the music yeah yeah then
once the [ __ ] music I was living in
Denver and I'm like I gotta get to
Seattle I mean I this is the weirdest
story I'm gonna hit the Seattle I hit
the Seattle and I made a [ __ ] grown in
Michigan she goes I'm going to Seattle
and I was like you know [ __ ] honest I
mean I was like come get me in Boulder
yes she sure [ __ ] Wow and and picked
me up and both we went to Seattle and by
the time I got up there you know
Soundgarden was huge yeah you guys were
the kings
all right 95 you guys want top of
[ __ ] well yeah I mean and that's
what's crazy like by the time all that
Seattle music came out [ __ ] constant
roses just you yeah Mike one of my
all-time favorite videos is
sweet child of mine MTV didn't really
have a lot of videos that year and sweet
child of mine who was on MTV 2 times an
hour every [ __ ] hour and I mean I was
gonna get locked up that August I was
going away to prison and that's all I
did all something was work go home and
watch MTV
and even when I got locked up I took
that cassette him with me nice of
Appetite for Destruction
what a [ __ ] what a life you've had so
you got a GED like me what made you quit
high school in the tenth grade I was
playing music I mean back then you did
do-it-yourself punk rock tours I was in
a band that started like going up and
down the coast and going other places
school wasn't really like you know 8:30
to 3 o'clock school wasn't conducive
with me having a job cuz you have to
have a job if you want to be in a band
you got a bike gear you got a Brent you
know whatever you got to do so I was the
last eight kids to I think by that time
my mom she saw that I was when I said
I'm gonna leave school I I was gonna go
to alternative school right but didn't
have a lot of those when we were growing
up they had Nova and this place called
Nova so I I got into Nova and I didn't
really go I that's when I just I kind of
became a lifer in music when once I left
like the high school was when I said
okay well you've made this big movie
better be all in you know you can't just
quit school and be some loser dude so I
really went all-in on I was playing
drums then I was playing guitar then I'm
based in I was trying to figure out
which I was gonna was gonna be my one
wasn't was I gonna be a drummer about
the same time I'm about sixteen years
old
heroin came into the Seattle this is 80
what 81 late 81 early 82 and it really
kind of this brown tar heroin came in to
Seattle and kind of took out everybody
out
playing with it didn't hit me I done
drugs and stuff earlier like really
young age like middle school you
probably did too it's our age group 12
that's well right we moved onto acid
acid sixth grade yeah yeah mescaline
members the cannabinol can never know we
had everything and in Seattle we could
pick mushrooms on the way home from
school you know but we knew how to
discern liberty caps from every other
mushroom by the time you're 13 years old
you're expert on like mushrooms and so
by the time I was 16 I kind of went
straight edge I'd had like a really bad
acid trip I had a really bad mushroom
trip I'm like okay I'm done I started
having panic attacks then I thought it
was from all the psychedelics so I I
wasn't like going to AAA meetings I just
stopped everything and it was just so
into music and that's what I that was my
drug about the same time heroin came in
and it took out like guys my band this
band we just like we were poised to make
that next move we toured with Black Flag
we toured Dead Kennedys which is you're
on your way up in that day and age right
my my roommate that I had a house with
he got strung out 18 my girlfriend got
strung out and at 19 I was at this this
point so it's 1984 and a friend of mine
was strung out he said man if you don't
leave now
and you gotta go somewhere you gotta get
out of here you're like our hope you
know you know my little group of friends
and my car I didn't think would make it
it was a 71 maverick slant six engine I
bought for 300 bucks like okay New
York's 2,500 miles away or whatever it
was
la is 1200 I've been to LA I played so I
said it south I moved to LA no how long
would you do the first couple of months
in LA I mean I was busy I got a job
first at Black Angus first day I was
here like on the way
I drove in submariner was I drove up
drove into down over the grapevine got
into Northridge the 405 right got
northwards I see lights
I must be in LA I didn't really know the
layout of LA I'd only played like the
Cafe de granted in Hollywood and and
some other you know so I'm here and I
pull off way out there and get a job at
the Black Angus I'm in LA I could I had
resume I was cook you know I had a good
resume with I got a job right there I've
been driving for whatever 20 hours but
when you're 19 you can do anything so I
got a job after that shift
I worked right then you started yeah
yeah got a job what are you gonna do
I'll give me some time no you stuck okay
I got a job I only had like 260 bucks so
I didn't have enough to get an apartment
I knew there would be a little swing
time in there so after that shift a guy
and older cook they confront line cook I
said how far is Hollywood he asked me if
I give him a ride home
may I give you write him was Hollywood
premiere he said Hollywood man that's
like 25 miles
okay so he gave me directions and I went
to Hollywood that night slept in my car
for the first couple weeks like washed
up work you know finally was able to get
apartment it's the cheap place behind
the Chinese Theatre the Olympics had
just left LA the Summer Olympics of 80
Couric's yeah so what I didn't know you
know now I have all this this this great
leisure of of retrospect right this
great knowledge of retrospect the 84
Olympics what the LAPD and had done it
cleaned out LA you ever heard about this
day yes I was here I would I came before
the over here I came and I my uncle said
he'd get me a job with the phone company
okay the Olympic now comedy was not on
my radar right nothing entertainment was
not on my radar I like movies [ __ ] like
that but
there was no way it was on my radar and
I came I think I stayed a week and then
we got into a beef he said I don't think
you really want to stay for the job and
I left but then I was here and I saw I
was just in shock I had come to LA a lot
when I was a kid to visit my uncle my
mom would send me the Disneyland
SeaWorld and all that [ __ ] but when you
live on the East Coast your impression
of him is beaches and blondes and
[ __ ] and next thing you know I'm
saying [ __ ] I'm in Glendale with it
looks worse than Newark New Jersey right
and I'm like what the [ __ ] is this is a
pipe dream right there's a beach but
there's all this other land that looks
like a bomb [ __ ] hit it you know yeah
so what our disagreement I got the [ __ ]
out of here but I didn't I would have to
go around on him buses and I saw how
filthy it was like I got I went to Halle
one day with him
you gotta pick up music or something and
I looked around on Hollywood no Mike
this is [ __ ] Hollywood but yeah it
was just awful
yeah so what the I guess what the it's
well known now but the cops came in and
they they cleaned out Holly wouldn't
cleaned out the place where people for
the Olympics would be they want to make
La look great and so that they I guess
they shipped like homeless people that
the Arizona or Orange County got the
hookers out got the drug dealers out
cleaned it up for that whatever it is
two months that the Olympics are here
and that unbeknownst to me I moved right
after the Olympics
September 14th and the cops just left
and so everything came back into
Hollywood is like the Wild West and I
got but the good side of that was rent
was super cheap nobody wanted to live
there and so I got an apartment for I
mean wasn't cheap to me 200 bucks a
month was a lot of money but I had my
own place was cockroach infested there
was the you know the police helicopters
all night long like just you know it'd
be right next to my apartment everything
whatever's going down I hear people
running by my window you know there's
bars on the windows it's culture shock
from Seattle for sure but that first so
I got a job yes what I did there was a
news
called the recycler which was Yuki and
everything from you know washing
machines and lawnmowers cars it's still
around this is it might be still around
it comes in like little magazine things
as you're walking out Hollywood you can
open it up and write and they had
musicians wanted musician things in the
back and I went through this like what
am I gonna do and there was a guy named
slash influent needed a bass player I
had a bass that had a don't think I had
I meant add a little amp and it
influences our Aerosmith and fear and
Alice Cooper I'm like that's right up my
alley punk rock was the hardcore kind of
come in and taking punk rock out of what
it originally was which was this kind of
open thing where everybody was invited
into this more restrictive uniformed
thing by eighty-four punk rock was
turned into this other thing well
documented so I looked at this Aerosmith
fear Alice Cooper the guy's name was
slash and I thought my name is Duff you
know I'm he's a punk rock guy now look
them to make whatever's next ours and I
went met slash and Steven Adler down at
the Cantor's restaurant they had a
bottle of vodka and we just talked about
music I'd blue hair they had this long
hair and it was that again was kind of
culture shock I'm sure I was me walking
in with like this
I had this my pride I still have this
black and red like John shaft pimp long
leather jacket and blue hair
it had Anarchy AAA on the back of the
second you know classic and so I think
we probably shocked each other but we
all talked to sing language as far as
music went and I went to slash served me
back to his house that night he blocks
away his mom's house he'd played guitar
and I'm like you're not old enough to
play like this like I've never seen
anybody play like he plays like he does
now he played like that then how old was
he that with nineteen she you all kids
yeah and a you know again I told you
before we started this like slash mom
was really like cool and generous
with me and I mean I didn't feel like a
young kid she saw me as a you know a boy
alone in LA up to me had toured punk
rock tour has done all this stuff I was
ready for what is Evers next but she was
remained in my life and my wife and kids
I had to come later on in their lives
too but then I met Izzy things happened
pretty quick you know is he moved into
the shitty apartment building across the
street for mine I saw this guy looks
like Johnny Thunders he's got like the
long pimp jacket - he's at the phone
booth and we talked and because I'm
starting this band me and my friend is
this singer Axl and I'd seen slash had
taken me to see this gig at the
troubadour or Axl as the singer of early
version of Elly guns and I saw this guy
come out and he was like Henry wrong you
know he was that intense him real and
like I backed up a few steps like one of
those guys and I loved I still to this
day I love the people guys are girls
that scare me somewhat you know where I
take a couple steps back because that I
love that intensity Iggy had that you
know Henry Rollins had that Bad Brains
had that Axl has that anyhow long story
short we started playing all five of us
together within maybe four months of me
being here so now it's 85 it's 85 I
think our first gig ever was a June of
85 I could be completely wrong someone's
gonna call and say he's totally wrong
but I think it was June any type of this
of that five now at this time Motley
Crue's was ripping it up a monic said
strip well different world that was like
they were huge
all those family crew rat mmm all those
tiny atoms were ripping it up at that
time yeah they were a few years older
than us right I think we really thought
whatever we were gonna do was gonna be
completely different we were gonna start
something new
and there was that was wasn't much of an
age difference but was we had called it
kind of come up in a different time than
they had or they have even the five
years difference of AIDS was huge huge
so we definitely were being our own
thing like we weren't paying attention
to Motley Crue or or or rat or anything
that was going on on the Sunset Strip
which if you came here in 84 you saw the
posters and uh you know like it was it
was weird you know the kind of almost
corporate rock rock bands you know to to
us it seemed that way they had money to
make posters and all this like elaborate
stage show and and we were really more
edgy and connected I think to the street
cuz that that's where we lived you know
we had a we eventually got a place
together behind the Guitar Center it was
just a room wasn't a garages
it was psych-out it was a storage space
it's still there it's still there still
though I lived on Gardner okay you might
move to Gardner 96 eight that's the
first I mean that was hookers in front
of the building and you know I was
[ __ ] this guy was a trader or
gardener gardener guard got it there
right other done garden yeah gardener
curse on yeah but our Sierra Bonita yeah
and Vista yeah those are the stream then
get out compadre across yeah yeah which
up my wife and I we were we were
visiting shooter we'll get into shooter
in a minute I'm sure but shooter was
producing shooter and Brandi Carlo or
producing Tanya Tucker record at sunset
sound so they they invited Susan I to
come by come and meet Tanya and check
out this song so we go down this only a
couple months ago
so we're down there we have a good time
my wife's drinking tequila with Tanya
Tucker it's just amazing you know Tanya
whatever force that woman is and Susan
and I leave it like let's get something
it's going to el compadre haven't been
there since the eighties no let's go and
we get there
they're ballet parking now yes you know
this yes I would find it it's finance
that's why I don't stop no more yeah cuz
they have valet parking Aaron you know
it was a [ __ ] wild wild west totally
you go in the bathroom is coke on the
floor [ __ ] they would close I love my
coke there yeah it's a crazy place but I
I used to stop there Mondays and I get
the chicken burrito
sure [ __ ] delicious by Kurt Fox comic
go to get the chicken burrito yeah no
good thing at the chicken burrito of it
and it's just but now the margaritas
were super strong yeah the margaritas
will [ __ ] you up yeah and so we went to
go there my wife and I and there would
Paul I'm like I got the secret entrances
in the back in the alley I go in the
back in the alley that's where like this
is the outside lounge there's valet
parking there there's like sir that's a
45-minute wait like what 45 minutes so
we didn't end up going yeah it's busy
there yeah that's where professional
zone everybody else goes to the standard
that wants to mingle if you want to get
[ __ ] up yeah and see the devil you
gotta get out compadre and meet crazy
women and the way this is doing blow it
makes itself still but can't get your
order of food because the way the forgot
he's in the back cut the gram and when
he comes me he's [ __ ] sweating the
guy playing the guitar was the coke
salesman so he would come to the table
and you throw money into the hole and he
would pop his arm and a coke rock will
fall out and he goes it was crazy
I've seen them carry out who's the big
time director now that did pop for a
cantina I seen him carry him out of
there like somebody had punched him with
a hammer like two Mexicans had him
around there Sheldon they would just
drag him they took the keys out of his
pocket just drove in the front seat
that's how crazy I've seen that place
yeah I mean when we were there this is
85 86 it really it was just like our
Clubhouse like el compadre across the
street when we had enough money to go or
so he said we'll take you over to el
compadre but yeah it wasn't we could
just walk in then yes you know in the
daytime it's wide open
you can't afford cocaine so I didn't
know if the waiters are at the cocaine
was coaching horses still there was
there at that time
two blocks up I don't know in curse on
we didn't wander up you just stayed
behind the guitar Santa sunset green you
know to me yeah all that yeah daddy's
was down the block yeah we filthy
[ __ ] Denny's answer it's the it's
that rest of my roma aroma now it's not
Denny's anymore no what do I know a
cross had a guitar center that way its
yeah he was a filthy Danny yeah but it's
99-cent breakfast yes it was no no it
wasn't filthy as the sense of the food I
was in a like late night one night some
crack hooker just sat next to me it's
not playing with my hair that type of
yeah oh yeah like we're eating breakfast
somebody just sits next day and says do
you want to date that type of [ __ ]
dirty it was dirty in there
oh yeah pee if you can't handle like you
got it you already knew what you're
getting yourself into
I'm sure but if you uh yet nineteen I
knew I was what I was getting myself
into
it was wow it was culture shock and
outlay like none of that kind of stuff
shocked me with the crack hooker like I
moved my second apartment when I moved
on up to it like a $260 apartment I
moved up to Franklin and El Cerrito so
now I'm out from behind I'm out of the
cockroach building really bad cockroach
problem like I got used to cockroaches
crawling over you at night you get used
to you got to sleep right you get used
to whatever your environment is you turn
the light on and get up with your la
weekly try to like you know W thousand
you know I got it but you got used to so
I moved to this building without as many
cockroaches and this is 80 whatever five
or six and um
sly still knows about me i this Disgaea
helps me move into my apartment he lives
next door to mine he goes what are you
moving in hop you move it and it's this
guitar player guy who became a really
good friend help help me right he showed
me open e tuning and i wrote it's so
easy like that minute westart keen he
was kind of connected to our band from
that moment on till he passed away but
he goes yeah man it's life
stone was upstairs I grew up to sign the
family stone but that was music of that
the flavored my youth I was in playing
in our house James gangs like the time
stone look what do you mean he lives and
this [ __ ] like JC
he's got hookers and he's selling crack
and stuff and that's why that was my
first aha moment like I just thought
signing the family like Sly Stone would
be living off in some fancy mansion
somewhere you know and that was a good
lesson I of course ran into him he
ducked into my apartment one time to
take a hit of crack somebody was after
him I'm like okay he gave me a demo tape
one time and I wish I knew where that
was it was a lot of us just crazy music
but some of it was amazing
I'm going down rabbit hole here rabbit
hole say I'm sorry no no it's great but
I'm like oh wow so Sly Stone that's here
like what happened yeah crack that's
what happen in that case but I don't
know I was getting at what would the
which is topological order before all
right type of discharge it must be kind
of crazy cuz when you move it like I've
been here for eight years in LA and to
most people that's nothing and it feels
like not that much time but then when
you look back at what you did you like
oh [ __ ] like a lot of stuff has happened
and to think about you like you you're
talking about like your how you go back
and forth between Seattle and I lay down
and then hearing about a two hundred
dollar month apartment where you got
used to cockroaches much yeah just blows
it blows my mind it's like wow so yeah
well you went through when you're
starting is crazy man I got impetigo I
thought I'd because I had my
piece-of-shit car I always had to work
on the engine like you know I remember
replacing a master cylinder I didn't
know you had to keep the things under
pressure master cylinders your brake
thing you have to keep the hoses under
pressure so I pull out I go to the
junkyard find a master cylinder the
match is mine right cost me 30 bucks I'm
gonna bring it back I'm gonna take out
the old master cylinder and put in the
new one that's for your brakes right
but the hoses and the brake fluid you
have to keep under so I take this thing
out at all this brake fluid goes flying
so then you have to find remember those
books on your your car's right remember
your car is yellow you guys see all the
[ __ ] equipment that's needed and
what's what it cost and it'll tell you
what you gotta do like you gotta keep
things under pressure and if you've lost
the pressure you got to do this whole
thing my point - that is not how to fix
a master cylinder 71 goddamn maverick
it's uh it said I thought I like I
rubbed up on battery acid like at the
battery too many times I started getting
these like what seemed like battery
burns all over me and it was I met some
woman and her dad was a doctor and he
said okay get battery acid burns on it
like it's like I'm my waistline like you
use you know whatever was baby powder
something's tried dad it got worse she's
like oh you should buy go to free clinic
or so her dad was a pharmacist that's
what it was it's all coming back to me
now I put the impetigo out of my [ __ ]
brain and but I go you get when you're
extremely dirty I go this free clinic
and I've been keeping myself clean you
know but my apartment was [ __ ] dirty
like you couldn't clean the felt out of
this [ __ ] place and in impetigo it's
like I think third-world babies get it's
this like bacteria so I got empat I go
for that first apartment wasn't battery
acid burns and then to you was it
exciting to be in Hollywood even though
you were in that shitty apartment like
who's that North Ridge was that's like
they like it it's like the Sun I got
they put yeah yeah like what were you
like super excited to be there I'm like
okay I'm in Hollywood it wasn't like the
movie I wasn't in Hollywood for the
movies I wasn't in Hollywood for I
didn't know what fancy stuff was I
didn't grow up with fancy stuff so all
of that was out of my head like those
you didn't go up in the hills because
that was fancy stuff up there might as
well not even go look at it I was here
for one reason that was I was a lifer in
music and I was there to find my band
you know
so having my own apartment was yes much
better than live in my car yeah yeah you
have any doubts at that time look any
doubts about going to see Alan you
always could get a job at Roy whatever's
and cook no I couldn't yeah I couldn't
come back with you know my tail between
my proverbial legs you know what I mean
I had to do it and I'm I you know people
have asked me like what do you tell
young musician I mean if you I couldn't
breathe if I wasn't doing music and I
tell anybody young if you if it makes it
hard for you to breathe to not do music
then you're doing the right thing you
know if you've got some back-up plan
this isn't gonna work it's not gonna
work if you got okay I didn't have an
option for college and have an option
for things you know which was that I
wasn't morning that wasn't like I didn't
know any different none of my other
brothers and sisters had the option
either
they went into Vietnam they wouldn't
yeah whatever
so no I was totally dead setting that I
was sure of myself and with what talent
I had I knew at least knew out of like
spot other talent I think was and I saw
Axl when when is he said acts I booked
starting this band with my friend Axl
they've come out from Indiana so I knew
they were in it too they had no backup
plan you wanted to find those people and
like Axl man I saw that guy it got super
intense and met Axl grew a mouth we
started playing and we got slashing and
Steven in and that was it the moment we
played our first and you rehearse tree
behind gardener that we finally got that
sock back to the room we're in
Silverlake yeah and then we got that
spot which I think that spot was like
300 bucks a month or four out of bucks a
month but no bathroom no kitchen no just
storage just to pull go in there and
lock yourself in and play and live yeah
Wally's yeah at certain times
all of us our gears that we built we
went to a construction site installed
some lumber and built flew in the joyed
the place wasn't much goodness no no no
I know those garage yeah built a little
loft above our ramps like a sleeping
loft just tremendous what was the first
time you saw any successful Guns N'Roses
when did you feel you were on the right
[ __ ] path um
well that was we just kept writing songs
at that point and playing little gigs
three people you know 5 and the 3 people
was like Westar Keane his girlfriend and
the guy that's you know our buddy who
has a big enough card progeria but we
started we just kept writing songs and
playing more and more acts was super
he's like he's super driven guy he just
had a bigger um world view or our band
like he's like work that we're going
this is gonna be our next step in the
next step and like okay that sounds
amazing I don't know we're just writing
songs in our shitty little place and but
we started drawing more and more people
and getting better gigs and it was so
like to us like it didn't it happened
over we made like a mailing list we had
that we did all this stuff to like push
our band we'd go after fans you know
like keep on them get their address mail
and pliers so you know get the money for
poachers poachers stamps and all you do
is fold up the flyer tape the top put a
stamp in their address and mail it to
but uh we toured we made you know we got
signed to Geffen on the stipulation we
could I hope we had all artistic you
know last word on everything nobody
could touch our music that we could we
would pick the producer would pick the
mix we did everything pick the singles
all of that so that was a good fee
wasn't success necessarily yet and we
toured for a year and a half on the
record opening for everybody you know
like seven people coming to see your
band and we started to break in in UK
and that was a great feeling over there
go ahead and play we went and played the
marquee which is tiny and then the next
time we played we sold out Hammersmith
Odeon which is a big theater and that's
quite a jump so that was maybe the first
time I felt like oh we saw up the
Hammersmith Odeon and we were going over
to Japan Australia Australia and getting
some sub moment there in the u.s. was
such a big market really commercial you
know it's like roxette's Madonna
Whitesnake with that big record that we
were nothing like leopard has a big
album Def Leppard 8687
yeah you guys released in 88 correct 87
87 yes Emma maybe seven or something
I think it was of June of 87 when the
album took a long time to catch on if
you thought we came out in 88 cuz it
took a year and a half it took because I
got sentenced in 88 and by that time you
guys were off and running right
everybody knows the [ __ ] dungeon roses
oh yeah I bumped into I bumped into
slash when I first moved here I had a
couple was a pseudo comedy club on
Sunset and st. much when I saw him again
at The Comedy Store didn't say much then
I got on a plane with Rogen to go to
Vegas 98 maybe and I saw him on the
[ __ ] flight with us I didn't say
nothing I went to a hotel that night I
have insomnia
I had no weed in Vegas no money I was
broke and I said let me just go for a
walk and I saw slash there's a kind of a
game convention or hmm a comic book or
something to do with something you know
and he was at the bar and I that's when
I said he's by himself let me go up to
him to ask and I'm told I remember going
you know I loved your albums but what
really happened with Axl and you know he
could have told me to go [ __ ] myself and
he goes
you're a comedian radical yeah it was a
you hungry right now are you I go yeah
I'm a long time you gonna remember these
times so when you get successful you can
look at this and see that you did the
work that's all that counts
I want you to remember that you did the
work you know that you put in the hours
I'm not resonated with me yeah this day
it resonates a lot and from what you're
telling me it seems like the guys that
you got very lucky because the guys you
in the bandwidth had the same dream you
had or even more powerful that lifts you
that's gotta be lifting yes the lines of
ice and the year will no be playing the
hammerschmidt whatever the [ __ ]
you're like how much dope did you do
last night but then you go home and you
like maybe he's got a point
yeah you know somebody asked me about
this and I've never fortune maybe I
don't know if luck if there's luck
involved you put in there the work you
put in the 20-hour days you know day
after day we were hurt twice a day we
were all in like we didn't have hobbies
we didn't have other things that were
outside it was all about the band and
you were like a family that yeah yeah
you guys just not together [ __ ] chicks
together do drugs together starve
together all of that put everything one
into a pot that's that that's it that's
a big thing to learn in life yeah we
were separate from from we felt separate
from everybody else in in Southern
California not just LA and we were like
this little gang you know
protected each other but did all that
stuff and so you know we I think we
wrote the right so we're really super
hard on ourselves but what's writing we
wanted the best thing you know you got
your you get your feelings hurt a lot in
a band situation you're not a solo
artist right this is like everybody's
wanting to make that song the best so
that riff that you just brought in you
just something in your band just like
side comment that sucks you know and
you're moving on you got you can't you
got to grow a thick skin and and serve
like the song and serve the band and so
when our kind of number was up it wasn't
a
lucky break we had just done all the
work and you know maybe fortunate that
that the timing of our songs the subject
matter struck a chord with the rest of
when it finally got out struck a chord
with the rest of the rock world you know
the kids our age
these were we were it was finally kind
of like a truthful voice of what was
really going on in life kind of like the
NWA record was a couple years later you
know so I think that was it you know but
we were all super driven like we would
have done anything for the band was a
weird that you found like it sounds like
these people were the first people that
you met in LA like to me it would seem
that you would go through like five six
different bands before you know I was I
played I was playing with other people
in Seattle Bernal age in LA okay I I was
you know I was meeting a lot of people /
wasn't the only person I found okay I
just like you like opened it up saw him
and went to K nur's and that was it no
there was no real idol time in my life
you know I'd work finally got a job in
Hollywood so I was playing music all the
time but this was the thing once I think
once it was axel Izzy we started playing
together it wasn't slashing Steven at
first it was it two other guys / -
Steven Wilbur Traci guns no Traci guns
and this guy Rob Gardner when guns first
okay right and we'd book is in that book
this is kind of punk rock tour because I
was used to doing this this West Coast I
knew other Club guys in the crash houses
where we could crash ships all done we
had a guy who would drive our gear we
got a u-haul trailer and and that that
was kind of the like
shit-or-get-off-the-pot moment for for
guns in the history our history Traci
and Rob but just like a bad but I'd
never done like a tour and like didn't
put these are punk rock tours then we're
not like exactly new were you're gonna
sleep that night you didn't know exactly
how you're gonna eat but I'd done it so
many times there is he an expert like
okay let's go we got gigs
let's go and those two guys Robin and
Tracy just right but basically last
minute like we're not gonna do it that
just sounds too you know winging it
and to me that was normal like ice no
these were normal things you did it's
what you do and and that was I want to
cancel in this to work man
and that's when we got together with
slash and Steven but more than that I'm
what we got together with those two guys
it was the first three chords we played
it was like oh that was the best move
ever made and we were off to the races
when did that tour well we only made the
first gig which was in Seattle a car
broke down in Bakersfield
so we hitchhiked the five of us to
Seattle you know that's right
we hitchhiked picked all five of you up
1,100 miles with a sect thousand miles
we were eating onions out of the onion
field and like Bakersfield and we had 37
dollars all right between us so we went
to the truck stop and there was a
trucker there God was tweaking out of
his mind on crank he said so we need a
ride we're going to Seattle because I'm
going to Medford how much money guys
guys DeLorean yeah I miss money yet we
got 37 bucks
I give me a 37 bucks and I'll take you
to Medford and the guy was we all got in
the cab you know like safer like our
guitars and the guy did he got us too he
dropped us off at one point in
Sacramento was like a hundred and ten
degrees man and we're at there like the
Capitol building on the lawn there's
water fountains and stuff and the
trucker takes off for like he's dumping
us here man but he I think he just went
to go get more crank and sure enough he
came back around got us like an hour to
God's to Medford we hitchhiked we've got
one ride from Medford on the 405 you
know
Mexican guy with his little pickup but
we got all got in the back and it was
rubbing the tires he's like I'm sorry
you guys he took us like five miles his
back tires were smoking I'm sorry you
guys.i it's gonna ruin my truck I wish
you the best of luck and then these uh
so we're out there you know now we're
north of Medford somewhere and we're
hitchhiking and that this this pickup
truck a real one like a regular sized
pickup truck with a cap in the back
these two women in their 30s so they
were old to us they said you guys were
you going yeah he said we're going to
Portland we could take you that far but
this point I'm like okay I'm thinking I
can call friend in Seattle come down to
Portland to get us and we're get in the
back of these this girl's pickup I'm
just like that corrugated back you know
cab but they had a window up to the
front and they said you guys they said
look we passed you guys and then we
turned around and came back guy you
because we used to hitchhike we're
hippie girls nobody pick us up because
the way we loves and we just did that to
you
we passed you and then we talked and we
said we just passed people that well I
got so we passed them for the same
reason because they don't look you know
they look different and they they're
really sweet I I wish I would have
remembered their names because they you
guys hungry starving okay we're gonna
stop and get some gas but you guys some
sandwiches just come on in the store
with us we got some beer you know she's
just like angels picked us up and at
that gas station that called collect and
my friend Donner in Seattle I said man
we're on a mission to check in since
Bakersfield can you come get us in
Portland he's like I'll do that and not
only that I'll throw you guys a party
when you get to stay out of like
nobody's ever seen so we get to Portland
there's Donner he picks us up these
women drops off good luck guys you know
never got the truckers name
he was so tweaked down on meth I don't
know
we got Seattle there was like this house
parties
beyond house parties though as barbecue
and you know bows and checks everything
and it's like got a welcome my new
friends you know see how like this is
our band especially after that
hitchhiking trip we were a band yeah
like don't [ __ ] around with us it's over
yeah
the gig we played and see how we are
geared didn't make it cuz the car broke
down so we borrowed the fastbacks gear
who we're open up for a band I used to
play and play drums in there was nobody
there we sucked but didn't matter at
that point didn't matter what songs were
you doing that you remember I know you
remember you were [ __ ] genius well we
were to it like we had jungle we had
those [ __ ] yeah we had and we were
playing like we have a new box set that
came out last year and it has all these
Sound City demos we did and that kind of
gives you get an indication of what we
were playing it like Heartbreak Hotel by
almost like the speeded-up version
reckless life off of our first EP nice
place don't play rock and roll but Rose
Tattoo we're playing covers but we had
our own song we had a good grip by that
point like eight or nine songs we played
it probably don't cry jungle of course
now in Seattle like 2000 people said
they've been at that gig that first game
we played well there was only actually
three people there we sucked I'm glad
people were at that show but that was uh
and we got back to LA we couldn't do the
rest of the tour because the guy with
had the car with the u-haul and our gear
the car never got fixed he was trying to
get it fixed our hopes where he get it
fixed
meet us in Seattle would be able to do
Portland Eugene Sacramento San Francisco
but we never did but we made Seattle and
we made our way back we did our a show
somewhere when we got back because we
had an ally gang at the end of the this
tour and might have been at the
troubadour I might've been opening on a
Monday night for two other bands you
know that's where you start there and we
did it man we came back like changed
people thing kind of any United pan and
how long then
you have to recognize don't cry you
already had don't cry then why didn't
you put that on appetite gradually yeah
there was some songs from before I mean
there was Axl started November rain he
had this like thing all the way back
then he had this PN like any time with
things we didn't have piano right so any
time we'd get around a piano he'd start
playing this thing and he had like this
this melody he might add in words but
yeah when you don't have a piano like
how you gonna develop a song and he did
over the those like four or five years
he developed by the time we made the
Aleutians record he had this whole thing
but there was bits and pieces to all
kinds of songs we just sat on that I'm
stood in that lived in that little room
and just wrote song so don't cry yeah I
was why didn't we put it out on appetite
think probably sweet child but I took
precedence I don't think we child's a
remake right well you guys wrote that
originally we wrote that we wrote okay
yeah there was some loss I thought was a
remake but no no I thought I had for
some reason I just thought oh well
[ __ ] did it
oh yes ice water that's who we Billy
yeah yeah yeah listen Tom the ID on the
plane the secular third Sheryl Crow my
favorite mistake that out put it on that
one that's what we just did it like an
app for a soundtrack for some movie I
remember getting the license request
okay I think that's the first time so he
made remade I was like ninety-four
writer 98 was a 98 I had what I know my
time you have so many like listen man
you're why I wanted the gays you're not
like most musicians her musician has
their own path you do something that I
believe in a lot I forget who said it
now McCart are one of those guys and
moving to air in the area with
excellence you know you like you just
said it earlier even though you were
hanging out with slash and those guys
you were hanging out with other guys too
Oh like you've always been when did you
cut out I mean you know in 1991 cons was
the biggest sound in the world you know
use Your Illusion one of the two came
out November they hit and it's something
like that mainly if you say so yeah yeah
like wanted to and Burton I broke rice
and I do a podcast about a year and a
half ago and we went off on a guns like
I didn't know Bert like guns Bert
Kreischer do you know that comedian him
and I just went off like we started
playing videos like it wasn't even a
podcast it was like yo I'm TV raps we
just kept playing you know don't cry and
all that use Your Illusion stuff we got
so many [ __ ] emails because a lot of
people don't you know a lot of the young
kids they didn't listen to that [ __ ]
right you know they listen to that they
listen to something else
we got nobody hits I mean I loved MTV
and even that you guys put those videos
out you just flipped MTV they were like
[ __ ] ballads like a short movie it's
like you know don't crime what was the
other one November rain rain rain
[ __ ] beautiful I mean you guys just
took videos and flip them now your first
solo out was 93 yeah was it yeah 93
you're right right right the tail end so
I was basically making demos really like
for the next guns record or whatever but
I I was a drummer right so I played
drums on the record and I played bass
and I play guitar I got some guest
people come in but we were traveling on
that illusions tour was was massive and
I took a little solace like God out of
the fray of the tour by going like
getting little studios in Dallas or
wherever the hell I recorded that record
I was I was pretty out of it but I made
wrote those songs and and I want him but
led to to the next and some of that
Gavin said we just put out a songwriter
at the end of the solutions to her and
you know if I were to look at myself
then from where I am now I would said no
you're gonna go get clean which did
eventually happen to me so
went out and toured straight after the
two and a half years of illusions oh I
had a band got a band together and we
went out to back to Europe open up with
scorpions on a big like tour did a bunch
of our own shows did some LA I did some
us dates we were set to go to Australia
I think and the gigs were doing really
well you know what Japan came back we
were supposed to Australia and something
like I was I just woke up on day I just
bought my house in Seattle like finally
back home on this is it man I finally
got the house like in the neighborhood
we used to steal cars from you know like
the other side of the tracks I got a
house tab we lived on the other side of
the tracks but I the other side of the
tracks for me was like this neighborhood
on the water like with big houses and I
was able to get this house there this
house on the lake you know at least you
still boats and cars and everything from
the statehood and I got this house and I
had like a bed my managers got me a
big-screen TV back when they were huge
so the box for that TV came in was my
couch in this house like he's just sit
on it right and he make it a couch and
you know and I woke up one day and I had
like what I thought was like a sharp
kind of gasps pain and I've I'd rolled
over like trying to get it out and of
gasping it's just spread across my like
whole midsection and drop down into like
my right top of my quad and was
everywhere and I couldn't
I moved again and it spread like over
across the rest of my intestines and I
knew something was really wrong and I
couldn't reach over to the I had a phone
next to the bed and I couldn't reach
good every movement just hurt it was
like dull knives pouring into me and I
couldn't reach the phone to call 9-1-1
and I just lay down I'm like what this
is it whatever is wrong had no idea was
wrong but then is it
it's over you know that was kind of
thinking that day would come
she wasn't sure when and a lot of
thoughts came to my head then like man
part of my whole dream wasn't like when
I was 16 17 and 18 saw my friends
getting strung out like that wasn't part
of my dream like becoming this bad it
was just to play music was all the
things I just told you about like moving
to LA finding your band doing that thing
being able to like hitchhike 1,100 miles
and being aware and write the songs and
do the stuff and do the work and here I
was I couldn't reach the [ __ ] phone
next to my bed and my best friend and
he's still my best friend we've been
best friends since we were three he came
out I heard him downstairs he came to my
car was in the garage so he knew I was
home my keys my wallet were downstairs
so I'm here I'm like where are you man
well he comes up the stairs and he sees
me on the bed say oh [ __ ] finally
happened I was bad for a few years
before that so he got me to uh there was
a doctor like two blocks from my house
an office but and this doctor his dad
had birthed all of us kids so it's the
doctors son had become a doctor go to
the doctor's office and answer I
couldn't talk right I could barely move
like and even the car ride just getting
down from my bedroom extremely extremely
painful it took me in the docs office
there was nobody in there the doctor
came you know okay well how much is
what's he been doing like what's his in
sick I don't know you know it was like I
wasn't there they were having this
conversation I couldn't talk shot me up
with two shots of Demerol I knew what
that should do it didn't do [ __ ] and so
they took Andy got me to Northwest
Hospital doctor said you'll get him
there faster than the ambulance if we
call him I go now I'll meet you guys
there and they got me into I mean I
could I took me into the emergency room
I was laying on the ground I couldn't
move and they got me in and
shut me up morphine and all kinds of
stuff did it
my doctor arrived they did have
ultrasound they didn't know what's going
on but he had an idea like I was
alcohols if drugs and was checked my
heart my pancreas it had expanded the
size of a football burst so it was all
the like the UH the enzymes that digest
your food were on the outside so it was
just eating up you know the outside
intestines and stomach and quad muscles
that's why I felt it down there and so
what they do you know I mean it was very
beyond serious at that point um my
doctor they were gonna go in and take
part of it out I'd be on dialysis at
best if I didn't you know die of shock
from the pain at first right I'm hearing
all this stuff going I signed the guide
the surgeon comes and I signed the thing
I'm like just I told the guys to just
kill me I can't take this like I'm on
morphine now I'm starting to have
withdrawals from alcohol right so they
give me a Librium and the other arm
right because you could die from alcohol
withdrawals right this is all all fresh
news to me as it's going down the
pancreas bursts sizable football there's
enzymes on the it's eating and they're
gonna stay open up your stomach
so let's team out to relieve some of the
pain before you die you know okay but I
just told the surgeon but just just kill
me man I mean there's nothing left for
me and they didn't so I've spent a night
there like ice chips had Librium in one
arm with the button right and I'd had a
morphine in the other arm with a putt
buttons on both of its just pressed the
buttons continuously and the ice chips
are I'm in intensive care so there's
always somebody there and they did an
ultrasound before the surgery and my
pancreas is actually kind of come down
back down and my doc said we're gonna
wait the surgery and just kept me on ice
chips and the bedroom in the morphine
and
checked again didn't I ultrasound that
night it kept coming down and my doctor
by the next day they did another
ultrasound he goes okay listen man I
want you to hear me
you've been given a second chance don't
[ __ ] waste it and I stayed in the
hospital for about 14 days that hospital
they moved me out of intensive care
after about five days they took the
buttons away but sucks you know and then
I went but I mean my mom had Parkinson's
I told you have eight kids my family my
mom was much older than me but to see
your mom in a wheelchair you know with
Parkinson's crying because her son's got
tubes running I just you know it's like
levitated above the bed and I'm looking
at her and looking at me and look but
the order of things is wrong here I
should be taking care of her you know
you failed you [ __ ] up you know you
[ __ ] [ __ ] so that was my calling you
know like I was saying okay you've
you're off booze you know even though I
had things in my arms I'm get you off
booze you off cocaine you off all the
other drugs like this is your chance
like the doctors voice reverberating
around my head don't [ __ ] up don't [ __ ]
it up you've been given a second chance
and seen my mom and all of that and it
really changed everything man for me and
I came out of hospital they had a rehab
for me to go to them I'm done I am done
I didn't know how to live you know but
that was a long time ago now you know to
recall that it now it's starting to seem
like a long time ago maybe ten years ago
it wasn't that long ago but now because
I think I'm you know eventually I met my
wife like I went got into martial arts
after that after the rehab no rehab I
was I had to come back down to LA from
Seattle I didn't know how to even buy
[ __ ] grocery sober driving my car was
like are you kidding me all you smelled
was brake pads because I was like so
[ __ ] tan so I was I was on the brakes
and and going into a grocery stores like
here on the acid you know hearing the
voice come out of the thing cuz you're
so sober you're not used to it and
crumpled up like dollar bill
sweaty all the time I was riding
mountain bike with my jeans on you know
because I had to do something and
somebody introduced me to sensei Benny I
was going down the North Hollywood goals
I was doing everything riding my
mountain bike then I'll go to Gold's did
not a workout got some guy said there's
a trainer there you know he can help you
figure out how to work out this guy who
was like okay then I said you know I've
got some issues my pancreas just burst a
sec all right
I worked out there for about a month and
I saw this kickboxers it's got Danny
come in it was a professional kickboxer
and he was doing all the stuff on the
look on his face and all I'm like I want
with that guy and somebody took me two
doors down to the back of sensei Benny's
dojo houses champions and there was
since a Benny in the book he could see
right through me all the way down to my
car and I started talking he goes uh
because you want to you want up you want
to be part of this this this is a
fighter's gym and and you do you'll do
what I say you'll work hard and there's
not gonna be a lot of conversations here
you show me you work hard you can stay
so I just man I was in that dojo two
times a day I just wanted whatever I saw
and since I've been his eyes that
knowledge and that depth in there they
didn't seem to be freaking out because
they were on alcohol and drugs and they
had a calm about him and and I stayed in
that dojo I stayed close to that dojo
for two years straight you know two days
no touring at that time no nothing
where was guns at this point mama this
is 94 and 95 I didn't think I could play
music again I thought you know when you
get sober that's that the misnomer right
that's what I kept that's why I didn't
quit coke for all those right yeah
you're not gonna be fun you know you're
all crazy
yeah I'm probably talking too much for
this [ __ ] podcast but no I love this
all right but yes take host that dojo
and I
got us start getting honest like myself
which is a turn of events you know to be
deeply honest with yourself when and you
do simple things like you come home to
your answering a machine like those
calls you wouldn't return I was
returning every call I was making my bed
I wasn't leaving dishes in the in the
sink
right I was like keeping my house clean
washing my clothes so you to overcome
addiction you have to get your character
yeah your character comes into question
a lot we didn't want to overcome an
addiction yeah same thing happen to me
yeah same thing happened that's what
comes back is that character that you
[ __ ] shot away so all away and drank
away that little guy yeah well it's you
and him when achieving and him alone
you'll throw the cigarette out the
window on Laurel Canyon regardless of
what you'll throw McDonald's [ __ ]
soda out the window you'll litter you'll
do little things that cuz guys like you
and I always do the big things yeah it
was little things we stopped doing that
what amazing right it's the little
things I tell people on this podcast I
don't give a [ __ ] about your big
accomplishments give me ten little ones
and that's bigger then I started being
polite to my wife I started all these
things I mean you went through a couple
divorces so you can write it off today
where they were both before before yeah
yeah it's it's just the things you see
and then you are around martial arts
which is that brings character back
quick when you have three or four gold
albums but at the end of class you're
mopping down the max you are mopping
down you're mopping down them good no no
those fighters need help I was I didn't
care I didn't give a [ __ ] ya didn't give
a [ __ ] didn't give a [ __ ] no but I
finally you know so I've worked out I've
learned his step jab step jab you know
defense diva jumping rope doing all this
stuff my body started really start to
change and I was riding my mouth lock
I'm doing everything I'm like I said
like 50 pounds of just booze weight you
know in this very short amount
five months it just fell off and when
you're in hitting bags and jumping rope
and and carrying a dude upstairs you
know you know we're gonna do that 50
times okay you know you just you've got
to drop the dojos no a/c in there
there's upstairs the upstairs is the
golden room right it's all about 115 up
there and your your your spawn on the
floor not in the ring yet not allowed in
the ring yet you haven't earned the ring
yet you know you do your stuff up here
but that that moment when sensei said
you ready for the ring to it's today and
there's PD Cunningham up there getting
ready for a fight in Paris and if
anybody knows Sugarfoot Cunningham yeah
he was the best in the world
middleweight fight the best in the world
period at that point 95 needs sparring
partners get in PT Cunningham axe kick
left his shoulder act to the right I
couldn't jab I couldn't punch you know
he's just
I had headgear on he's just banging the
crap cake a little punch and I'm just
trying to move trying to give him some
work I know that's what I'm supposed to
do and I did a couple rounds with him
and just beat the hell and he said oh
you tell your friends you did two rounds
with the world champion like okay I
didn't do him very well
lost almond I call it I got beat up I
get beat up every time I got a kick
boxing that's part of the little things
yeah it's little things because that
getting beat up make you more humble
yeah on the outside yeah I got really
humble you get really [ __ ] yeah and
you're thankful for everything when did
you decide to go back to school
alright so well okay so I met my wife so
I I did start playing music and and
Steve Jones one of my heroes from Sex
Pistols had been sober for a couple of
years and and Shannon had just died and
there was this benefit for Shannon's
wife and little brand-new daughter right
and he said Steve called me Steve gentle
my hair I uh uh you want to play show
with me at the at the Viper Room we're
gonna raise some money for the Steve
Jones
all right I don't Steve I don't know if
I can play music up so but I know you're
sober mean I've just I've heard that's
why I'm calling you because you can play
it's gonna be okay and Steve just Steve
Jones telling me it's gonna be okay so I
went down and rehearsed with Steve and
John Taylor from Duran Duran and and so
on Matt so I got the set together and I
could play at the rehearsal place just
fine playing guitar in this thing right
now bass playing guitar but I'd learned
to play guitar all my guitarist for
Steve Jones like now he's gonna see like
any Jeeves I think at that point used to
people like a lot of people cop Steve
Jones guitar licks and so we played this
gag man I was scared and I had you know
sensei and all the stuff in my head I
was like chest up you know head up you
know it's okay but it's like getting in
the ring it's okay like you're alright
you've done all the work and I got on
the stage played to show people said I
played better than ever
perhaps people thought I had like
plastic surgery and like because I'd
look so different you know all these
rumors Jonesy so I got people thought
you got a facelift and I was like oh
what and but I could play and we started
playing gigs and it's called neurotic
outsiders and and so now it's like 96 I
didn't know how to be like with a woman
I didn't that was kind of far off my
radar I was reading books at home but
working out I was like a monk you know
but that this I was out on this tour and
this guy from two Astra magazine I was
in Detroit
he's like hey man I know you've been
like sober for a couple years you know
like you had a bad time with women and
he goes but it's just girl I grew up
with she just moved to LA I'm gonna like
put you guys on a blind date like you
got to be good to god I've known you
since 86 I've known her since she was a
kid yeah and she's a model but she's
like just moved from Paris New York back
down to LA and like I don't know if I
want to get into that world you know
like I my world is so simple right now
because her world she's like you she's
from Bowling Green Ohio
she really didn't get mixed up in all
the cocaine in the Molly where all that
stuff she's really and he put her on the
phone we got to my room went up to my
room called her on the phone and she
sounded like one of my sisters so I'm
really calm really I talked to her a few
times on the phone through the rest of
the tour and she came and picked me up
at the Burbank Airport I flew from
Phoenix to Burbank cuz I'll just pick
you up what she didn't tell me she want
me to know where she lived because she
thought I was a you know I could
potential creep right and never know you
know she was totally right so she picked
me up at the airport and it was Susan's
my wife you know and this this woman
like this one before TSA and all that so
she met me at the plane she was all
dressed up I'm wearing like sweatpants
and a wife beater and tennis shoes and
she looks amazing and I'm like oh crap
all right so I'm eight listen can we go
to my house just so I can at least
change like we can't kind of dinner with
ya I just thought she was gonna pick me
up and we go get some simple thing but
she was dressed to the nines and she was
the sweetest girl on that first date she
was just like the girl I talked to on
the phone and she was really nervous you
know I found out okay she was uh she's
Susan Holmes like it John Taylor like I
knew because John Taylor from Duran
Duran was in our band Iraq Outsiders he
was way more into the fashion world than
I ever knew anything about he's like man
this girl you'd show me pictures of her
like this is my dream girl and it was
Susan Susan and like I know who you are
I actually know I've seen pictures of
John Taylor's got a big Russia she's
like oh that's sweet but she was just as
met Susan and we kind of not been apart
since that first date night so I we you
know I kind of had like tell her like my
story you know and eventually not that
night but over the next couple months
you know I said you know I've been
married a couple times and I was to die
alcoholic and drug addicts you know I
was knew I was gonna die and I was kind
set for it and almost happened it didn't
know I do you see I go to Sao Joao all
the time that's my thing and I might
miss mount bike this is gonna be my
thing and by the way I just got Sonic's
tickets for like 21 games courtside I
hope you like basketball because I'm
that that was I mean that was me making
it was being able to get courtside
tickets you know 95 96 socks come on
[ __ ] yeah come on and she was got amping
[ __ ] that was [ __ ] yeah can't that rain
man
yeah the rain man yeah the gloves her
see Hawkins see Hawkins Jesus Christ
yeah we I mean what a team that was and
uh yeah any how are you doing that you
know we could we could spend an hour on
the team I'm taking a lot of you guys
time but uh Susan I then she got
pregnant with great I was now I'm
sticking about school like I want it I
need to I've been reading all these
books
I knew I'd made money I didn't know how
to ask about I'm talk about my money I
was kind of first to money I would
really like I didn't ever get into music
to make money but then again I true
since I've been a and stuff in in
angling in the ring and defense and
fight your opponent fights you and
redirect and all of this stuff I I was
learning about my own life as well right
take control of things you can take
control of and my money was one thing
and I didn't know how to ask the
questions so I started taking some
business classes and I got myself into
see out of you eventually so it's real
long into their business school so I was
G I went to Seattle you about GED right
and I taken a couple business classes
and I said write your check you know I
want to go to business school they said
you can't come here with it what kind of
[ __ ] are you you know like you have to
so I had to go to Community College
across the street it's Seattle Central
and they told me what classes to take
and they say good all A's and maybe
what's you and I did I got all the A's
and then they said okay that's cool do
it again
told me what classes to take I did it
again and got all a eights and then they
said we read admissions essay what and
yeah I don't know ask somebody and so I
asked my friend Dave dieter who was in
presidents the United States of America
those guys all went to Ivy League
schools I known Dave since we were kids
like they wanted an essay for me and
what I say you know like what's it kind
of essay - I ran my story
you guys know telling me your home tell
them your thing tell him you your panco
six vote tell me your alcohol tell me
you'd move to LA
tell him you had this dream telling the
dream went astray for a while timing you
do martial arts tell them you met you
wipe done you got a little baby tell me
you're in Guns N'Roses it's give me a
whole story
tell him the truth so I wrote this thing
and it was [ __ ] gnarly well but they
accepted me in and yeah went to business
school
see how you albers school business go
Redhawks and and really my life was
getting just so much better day by day
with Susan that we had grace and I mean
so we had may two daughters who are now
18 and 21 so being able to be there and
be present and grow
every day I tried to at least you know
learn something new or be open-minded to
an idea and not be a closed-minded
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it's fun that you went to business
school you did not ask for money but I
think that the Sly Stone thing stayed
with him oh I think that that was on the
back of your mind that you did not want
to end up like [ __ ] Sly Stone of
course you guys sold I don't know how
many millions of [ __ ] records
worldwide you want to know what six-year
[ __ ] talk yeah you know there's got
to be a dollar somewhere
yeah I mean I knew I didn't know I
didn't know his hands were in it that
was the thing you know I didn't know
what a stock or a bond but I was too
ashamed to admit I didn't know what
those but then I when I would business
school I really found out like most of
us don't know what those things are what
interest rates really mean and how they
why they affect things and what risk
what investment actually means you know
what is a portfolio that's a fancy
[ __ ] word you know what does that
mean to me an investment portfolio so I
just took man I took a from the very
beginning accounting into finance into
you know macro economics micro we can
all of that stuff that you take and I
really I moved you know business
managers I said okay I I sort was able
to start reading our financial
statements and nobody really ripped us
off per se you know but there was it was
time for something new
for me to start fresh and I knew what I
was talking about as far as financial
statements went at this point and I
moved CPAs and started fresh and you
thought of a company well that was later
on much later on but you thought of a
company to pay some musicians could sign
with you or comedians or whether yeah
everything it was a more of an
educational I started writing for
playboy.com during the financial crisis
I was writing for the Seattle Weekly I
started writing um and an editor at
Playboy Tim Moore who had edited like
Norman Mailer Hunter has Thompson all
the stuff it's like you would be perfect
for this financial column I know your
business school like just tell people in
plain language what's going on so I
started this this column is a weekly
column at playboy calm got a lot of
feedback people are freaking out you
know people are like something
everything in their 401k like everybody
was freaking out and I was just you know
I kind of gave people the history of the
stock market in plain language if
something would come up that week and in
the news like these mortgage-backed you
know is mortgage mortgage backed
equities that were never selling what
does that actually mean
so I'd break that down what does a
mortgage back equity what does equity
mean you know what does a mortgage mean
so I break these things down and that
started getting a lot I could start
getting calls
a lot of friends like hey could you help
me out with my money
I'm too Maris to ask or you know what we
all are unless you go to [ __ ]
Business School I'm like do you have to
go to business school to actually like
know what you're talking about this
ridiculous should be easier than this so
I was thinking of just writing a book of
like a simple like that we could all
need this is what a stock is let's start
there
here's what a bond is I had one of you
books not the business one now not
hitting your agent bird level no I'm one
of the books because he sent me
he's a book agent he sent me a copy of
your book the first one was called it's
so easy in other lies the second one
about your kids you're both kind of yeah
there's one called how to be a man
another illusion no no it's that one all
right so it's the one you said before
kind of black cover ish yeah I still got
it at the house was weak is what I want
looking for it I have over a thousand
books in that [ __ ] house so I
couldn't find you yeah no I try to read
as much as I can that's all you got but
it's weird that so you went to business
school you know you do all this stuff
him now you realize you could play music
yeah so Velvet Revolver we started that
drama and that thing did really well and
now you know we were all fairly clear
head have got Scott Weiland he got sober
and and the first record and you know
that was really a we knew how to handle
ourselves business-wise - we're all you
know all that pretty much solves at the
dojo you know it was like we are 40 and
you know kicking ass is like we're you
know again we're on that kind of where
guns was when we are living in the
shitty garage because people doubted us
I was Gossett too dirty they're just
gummy - right never lyrics or about
drugs and [ __ ] nah we got that and it
revolving now it flash forward 20 years
or something either to hold you know
they're not in touch with what's going
on they play rock and roll it's never so
we just like blasted this this record
and kind of the whole mindset of that
record of that band was like we're gonna
go out and slay you know and it did well
you know it did it did really well
this point I'm you know Susan's now
seeing them like the rock world Nestle
said things slashes god mother's name
miss Susan Susan Susan little hippie
glasses okay I must I must know her
there you go but I don't know where I'm
getting to but um no but Susan got to
see now it's you seeing like then things
kind of started going sideways above her
office and drugs and some things and
some outside influences and things and
Susan's like whoa this world's [ __ ]
weird and she just wrote a novel she
just came out she took her nine years to
write it she worked so hard on this
thing but it came out a couple of weeks
ago and it's kind of I read pieces of it
as she was writing it but she wouldn't
let me read it until she had like the
final draft and she's like and she took
all of her experiences from her modeling
world and then the kind of like that
first thing into the rock world I made
this 90s novel that's pretty genius like
I'm like I know you got that story from
sort of you know but but my point to
that is her like us having two little
girls and there's like rock and roll
like hardcore we're touring up hard and
a lot and we learned how to be a family
like on the road and how long I can be
gone and not gone if it gets past 12
days it gets weird you know this I'll
come home for a day now the girls have
grown we've kind of passed that we've
been through all these cycles together
as parents like raising our kids on the
road they've now been able to they
traveled the world like eight times
you know they got that edge extra
education of being world citizens like
seeing this other cultures other things
going on but you know also raising our
kids through this social media age so it
kind of came in right when they're like
seven and ten like oh [ __ ] how do you do
this you know cyber bullying all that
stuff but I think from traveling the
world we've got we've got guns back
together it's like stronger and
or purer than it ever was like getting
slash and Axl really like again like
being on stage of them like show me what
hard work and being badass is is about
it like instills like that
that old thing like how [ __ ] hard we
worked and we never phone it in it's
never like a thing it's always real but
very interesting we got this like we got
our like the Brotherhood's back together
you know and it gives me this sort of
really sense of calm and we're about my
girls are now all date you know whatever
they were they were they're gonna be
good right
I've got college covered for him like
made a 529 be for both my girls two in
Business College Business School so
girls you get to go to college right
like that's what I didn't have you want
something better for your kids right
okay you know like guns this thing
started things sort of change on the
news before we went out like October
November December and I got sucked in
and I'm read a lot of books I read a lot
of history books I'm watching the news
I'm gonna suck down these rabbit holes
of these panels they're yelling each
other and this they're talking about
huge divide this is 2015 I'm like wow
this really interesting was divided but
I start to fall into it and when we
start rehearsing for the the guns tour
and I'm starting to follow people like
on Twitter I'm going down the wrong
rabbit and very unmeet thing to do my
wife honey goes you've watched a lot of
news and you're gettin kind of caught up
in this and you should probably stop
watching it is you know and I made this
purposeful switch right when we started
that tour in April of 2016 I turned off
all the news I shut my my home screen
was no longer Yahoo you know and I muted
all the I started following people on
the news so I could I was watching the
panel member this guy and I knew that
like they were yelling each other Newt
that was all to sell ads I know what the
cable news is about you know we all know
let's go if you read a book or five you
know it's like it's a commercial vehicle
right I went to business school I know
what they're doing so these panels
yelling each other must keep people on
on the channel longer right divide
divide all this stuff's going on let so
I turn it all off and I mute all the
people I'm following on Twitter and I
don't even look really a Twitter I post
like sound check picture sound chicken
you know it San Antonio and suddenly I'm
out seeing what I do on tour what's that
we didn't talk about on tour since I've
been sober I go out and see the things
that I read about in history books and
I've seen so much on this planet because
of that and I talked what what happens
when you go out and see go to Little
Bighorn let's say you're talking to park
rangers you're talking to people when
you go but the alligator guy in
Louisiana on the airboat you know you're
talking about a mark the alligators like
marshmallows who knew and then he told
me in the marshes disappearing I was
supposed to go down this way but it's
cut off now and he told me about how
quickly the marshes are disappearing and
all of these things I was doing like
every other day all around the world
nobody talked about a divide nobody
talked and I didn't feel a divine and I
wasn't watching the news and I wasn't
doing so I didn't have these influences
and I'm going around the world and I see
the woman with the full head covering
and Kuala Lumpur what the devil horns up
rocking it we're playing these gigs
where there's gatherings of you know
tens of thousands of people per gig and
nobody asks for you vote for when they
come in this show no it gives up five
[ __ ] yeah hey I call the news right
Lionel white people they just lie the
wife scaring wiping whether it's the
whether they petrified yeah normal
American you know last night 70
75 million people are in danger
tornadoes and they show Iowa and there's
nobody standing around what [ __ ] 75
million tell me that you hit New York
well a the news is there to scare white
people
I've said this fee is really gentrified
why people they buy into the news no and
then they go on social media and they
spew that shut and they make it bigger
than what it really is and at the end of
the day it doesn't affect who Duff
McKagan we saw how the Joey Diaz art the
end it doesn't really doubt ideas still
have to get up tweet [ __ ] feed this
kid taking a school it doesn't matter
all that it's unnecessary noise going
into your head that'll keep you up at
night
for no reason it has no effect on your
income there's no effect on how you
don't make an income because you still
gotta get up and stand on line and still
put your pants on one leg at a time yeah
so I just lost all this political talk
but there's infatuated our country all a
story is whether you want to hear it or
not cuz it's whether you want to hear
them that's right the first 10 minutes
of the news are going after the
president and the cabinet and it's all
something that does not affect you at
all it doesn't it does not affect your
income or anything zero it's just to
scare you and petrify you and [ __ ] on
your head before you leave the [ __ ]
house if you watch the Morning News
you're getting [ __ ] on your [ __ ] head
before you leave the house whether it's
the baby where they found in a dumpster
or the parents that you know rip the kid
out of the lady in Chicago
I feel bad as a human being but it has
nothing to do with him but so if you go
from politics to lady who got her baby
ripped out of her [ __ ] [ __ ] to the
Chinese guy who got beat up on United
you're leaving the house [ __ ] this is
what's in your mind while you're driving
it's doubting who you are as a human
being and doubt you yeah it makes you go
wash every thousand somebody's gonna
stick a finger up their ass for it my
baby out back at me all these [ __ ]
things that have nothing and that's why
I don't even get involved that [ __ ] I
told my wife as much as I love my wife I
got come in this house again I CMC SMBC
on I throw the [ __ ] TV out the
[ __ ] no more TV
as you know why not go to kiss it
affects you my wife gets very affected
by I see her at dinner I see when people
come over
she's from [ __ ] Tennessee you know
she's from the mountains of Tennessee
the biggest thing she ever saw was a
[ __ ] rattlesnake whatever the [ __ ]
they do up in Tennessee right I can see
it heart affected her ooh
and it affects a lot of people that way
I can walk into rooms now and definitely
see who know who watch the news and just
because I I got sucked down it to I and
I knew I was getting sucked is the
weirdest sensation like you know you're
getting sucked down a rabbit hole like
I'm on all three cable news networks I'm
following people like you're smarter
than this but it was a rabbit hole that
maybe I got sucked down I always choose
to believe I get said things happen for
a reason and when I turned it all off
and I and I got to experience the world
and I was reading books out on the road
I wrote read JD Vance's hillbilly ology
I read um Sarah Kandahar's view from the
flyover country I read the rise and fall
of the Third Reich
I read educated I read the grant
biography I've drawn chair notes grant
Macy but when you when you read these
things and I was kind of noticing taking
stock of like any positive change that's
happened ever like on this planet from
all the history I read it's not night I
mean it's not King it's not a queen it's
not a war maker it's not a president
like I played in punk rock bands and we
were railing against the lobbyists in
1980 you know like we knew the man
wasn't like the current president these
things they're so fluid they happen they
go away it's and we'll be pissed about
something else in two years I guarantee
you something completely other other
than what we're pissed about today I
guarantee you this is history that's
what happens but I did notice like the
small differences that we make like in
Seattle you can't help but see the
homelessness I wrote a song called cold
outside about like walking fast with the
keys in the hand like getting in your
car and getting the [ __ ] out and maybe
it's just maybe it's your fear of like I
grew up with Depression era our parents
right they grew up in the depression
your fear of like your only two bad
moves away from being their self is that
what you're scared enough and in the
Oviatt crisis and these things which is
a real [ __ ] thing you and I grew up
with drugs we know like
if the drug companies get involved [ __ ]
all bets are off because that's coming
that's coming used legit through the you
know I went to a a meeting at VA in
Seattle and I had to wade through the
line long line to the pharmacy to get to
the meeting and these kids I've climbed
mountains with these kids their kids man
listen miss and a leg just got back from
Afghanistan Marine they're 2120 it's not
there get them hooked on drugs and stuff
you know Marines there's so many
suicides they don't talk about these
these kids I've gotten to meet and now
hang out with the climb mountains and do
stuff don't you got to go to a me any
meaning out of be a check this out so I
did I went to and you got to wade
through all the people you know I'm
really waiting to pick up two
prescriptions and like so I I figured
out like these little ways to make
things better in my life and it's like
to those little things we were talking
about that making your bad boat for me
it's maybe okay I'm gonna go into the
jungle in Seattle and meet some people
maybe get rid of that at fear of the
others and maybe I could do something
one more step from that maybe I can get
some things involved like you know and
that's one I wrote a record while I was
on the road and it was gonna be a big
just a new one that's yeah maybe it's
gonna be my 31st May 31st right and the
name of the tenderness but that's the
name of the ow yeah are you doing
something on this out that I respect
totally cuz you and I discussed this
before we both have paper routes yeah we
both know what it is to save a couple
dollars for Saturday because you and
Nicky foot are gonna walk two miles to
the [ __ ] record store yeah
and you're gonna buy I could take the 71
bus I could take the 71 bus and I'm
struck by the clash live in London or
whatever think it is yeah and then we
get then you go I don't know if I want
Sex Pistols I'm gonna get hard second
out whatever the [ __ ] that is a because
that 10 bucks oh yeah if you had 10
bucks you're lucky there maybe was eight
now I see years ago I did a movie and
I'm
I sent me CD DVDs to the house and I
opened up the DVD box and there was
nothing and explained the movie and it
came to me what happened to the record
industry hmm thank you and I would go to
the record stores he you would buy now I
would buy one and then we go to your
house and port the liner notes read the
while ago I'm an event hailing 108 or
you knew where that record was made you
know produced it and one hotel they stay
there on the road yeah you want to thank
the holiday ends or the Hilton's [ __ ]
Four Seasons you knew and now you buy a
CD and it's not a laugh I see that if
you get tenderness it comes with a book
yeah yeah like you know you you on your
website you've all four different
packages for it like you could just buy
the album and you got like a sword or
something my sauce I'm clear but then
you have a package that has like the
book CD that's tremendous that your
people want to get yeah that's what
people want again and I think Brian your
manager sent me the liner notes and what
gave me the inspiration to write all
these songs and whatnot guess what
that's what people want to see again I
think people would go through the change
again I don't think we're doing this all
[ __ ] day but everybody you see I went
to New York last week at the ferry nine
people on the dock it's crazy isn't it
all nine or [ __ ] looking at something
your New York City has changed because
people are always on their phones but I
don't know about you my mother when I
got there from Cube my mother said keep
your little you look heads on a [ __ ]
swivel your heads on a swivel because
you don't know what's gonna happen
yeah me and me you're getting going my
pocket one time for a phone and if I use
the phone I walk over to the side and I
watch because they come up to me people
just walking with the head down I can't
[ __ ] it just killed crazy [ __ ]
kills me yeah now this drug you did you
do this out in which shooter all right
so I wrote the songs I was going to
write a third book like they had all
these ideas I was having these
experiences which I'm just telling you
about you know and I start writing these
little passages and I had acoustic
guitar on the road with me which I
always do and
in that rare moment that I'm in my hotel
because IMO is out seeing something I
was reading my word document I'm one of
the subjects I was I was writing about
and I had my guitar in my hand and I
started playing a couple chords to what
I written in came up with the first song
which is it's not too late which is the
second song on the record and I thought
I make this sort of this austere record
which I've wanted to make for 27 years
very toned down musical record I put
these words this record may be what I'm
thinking about which is a concept of of
healing of tenderness of doing something
for yourself and maybe just your
next-door neighbor like we did like
after 9/11 you know how we all kind of
closed in and like checked on your
neighbors and you had to grocery store
and somebody stumbled you're like okay
remember that there was no bill we asked
who you voted for then do you remember
that yes nobody gave a [ __ ] we were just
taking care of each other the hurricane
and Houston hurricane and we just took
care of people like JJ Watt raised that
pick to him like I'm in I like you as a
football player like okay how about this
and he people were taking care of each
other the fires here in California the
one that they portrayed on the news
before I left on this tour was this
divided fucked-up place and this is the
gun G&R 12 yes and in it and I
discovered it's not that at all and and
in this song this this album reflects
those discoveries I think in in a while
I offer yeah I wrote a whole like 3500
word thing I said along with the with
the record that kind of explains a lot
of things about the record and my my
worldview there's not a lot of me in the
record it's it's we and I hope to bring
them more people make people more aware
it's just like it's okay to turn off the
news is okay it's just a [ __ ] reach
out to your fellow man
- put your phone in your [ __ ] car
leave it there yeah so take the phone in
the kickboxing gym you know I dunno I
dunno I leave it in the [ __ ] car
I dunno today I took the phone I took it
from the car let's see if anybody had
called and was gonna run away that
whatever yeah and I went into the school
when I finished I had my hand wraps and
everything in there I try to remove
myself from this [ __ ] on the road now
there's no social media when I go on the
road I have an iPad but it just has a
Netflix and I have my writing app no
more social media on that yeah on the
road there's no Facebook I have Twitter
on the phone I want a life Facebook on
the phone I took a chance between 1 and
2 right cuz I was suffering from the
same thing yeah I could feel it I could
feel it I don't want to go for I want to
enjoy life I want to enjoy life on my
terms not reading about on a [ __ ]
Twitter yeah I see these people who
constantly every time I check Twitter I
see six or seven people or constantly on
all day and it breaks my [ __ ] heart
I had a stop last weekend went after a
girl cuz she lives in Thailand and she's
always talking about how Thailand is so
beautiful and she had like nine tweets
in a row that had nothing to do with
Thailand and I want other personal
message and I go if Thailand is so
beautiful why you [ __ ] tweeting so
much
I had a Colorado that like why you tweet
so in Thailand is this [ __ ] land that
you say about you should be sucking dick
and throwing cakes for Jesus out there
getting coconut oil rubbed on your
titties instead of being on [ __ ]
Twitter all day and on social media all
of that but anyway that's my view on it
why I don't disagree you're starting a
tower you're starting the tour may 30th
yeah Beauty is it goes back I want to
ask you why why are you starting in
Philly is there a particular reason
there really isn't I wanted to get to DC
and hopefully go to Walter Reed and me
and shooter go in and play for some of
the dudes
people out there so the first day that
might be too much so we're starting in
Philly it's a great rock town you know
as far as every band usually starts two
three I thought it was to get it out of
the way if you want this brushes thrown
at you
because it freely I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah they had in football they had the
only stadium with the court downstairs
that's how many people would get
arrested right yes that is that's how
crazy it was I don't know if the new
stadium has a jail underneath but that
just goes to show you know if you look
at those old videos from Bill burr when
he went to Philly and they heckled them
and they threw [ __ ] Adam so I once I saw
this I go is that why a CDC started the
back and black tour and freely if you
check it out July 31st 1980 it was in
frilly and then they went to the
Palladium on August 1st or something
like that but I saw a lot of schedules
that they will open up in Philly I know
why they open up in Philly and after the
built birthday because you want to get
that [ __ ] over with if they gonna throw
bottles at you you want to get a little
group with the first night just so well
yeah I don't know man I'm with shooter
shooter producer record I had the good
fortune of us crossing paths at the end
of my writing writing the songs for this
and he really bought into the whole idea
that I had and really mate took it from
there to the next level he is a next
level type of guy and and now his band
played on the record his band is gonna
be my band with shooter in it for this
tour we're starting in Philly where I
don't know why I've always had a good
time in film I me too I love Philly I
just kept saying why do [ __ ] people
start in Philly and then when I saw the
bill burr bombing like people throwing
things out of me should I go oh yeah
that's why I put that together with the
football and kick boxes we're tough guy
yeah we can take a bottle or two you
know but yeah but I you know DC but we
want to do some other cool things if we
can when we can and then you're back
here on the 13th and you know I'm going
you're going good I'm going like I'm
going to see I was supposed to go see
Michael Shanklin
okay 14th of May I really really wanted
to go I business I've had the baby I've
been living like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
how old is your baby six and I'm 56 yeah
so I've been living like a real [ __ ]
and I was psyched about going to see
Michael
at the trooper go over the cocaine was a
couple weeks ago was the April 14th or
something April 15 but I had to start a
movie that day and I missed out Michael
Shanklin when I was going over your web
page last night I saw you're gonna be in
LA and I go that'll be my first show to
break my cherry because that was showing
years I stopped going to show yeah come
to the show man yeah it's it's a that
night we're actually gonna have the the
horn section because it's my brother who
lives here in LA and the same horn
section my brother Matt now eat which
brother taught me how to play the bass
first now which brothers that was my
agents teacher in high school that's all
[ __ ] ya know he's hot he's been a music
teacher for the fact you went to visit
him when I've got out my agent said he
just one day brought nothing and tough
talk or something like that he played
the ukulele my brother's a legend out
there yeah you won the mr. Holland's
Opus Award look best music teacher in
the country you know you can only win it
once he won early but he also played
horns on all the gun stuff early their
first EP moved the city live and let die
that that horns and piccolo the piccolo
is his wife by an applet Dan on it but
Luke Danna
JIT so the suicide horn section is what
we called him so they they played on
this record and they're actually gonna
play with us on the song you play at the
end don't look behind you they'll come
out at the end of our set and play which
would be a special moment for me my mom
got to see my brother and I we opened
for the stones and 89a Coliseum
down here in LA flew my mom down and her
two sons were up on this suicide horn
section played with us that night my mom
got to see that I want you to miss your
mom though yeah yeah so uh so my brother
be there that night in El Rey will be a
good show but all of them I'm looking
forward to playing Nashville with this
with shooter and that band would be
different it's gonna be a different
world for me you know like a lot of this
this stuff I'm getting played on outlaw
country and Americana stations which is
something I've never been exposed to I
didn't intentionally make it outlaw
country or Americana record this
just as austere songs that wrote and and
shooter took it to the next level and
I'm some I'm to being exposed to some
cool stuff I gotta tell you when I
listened to the album
I was writing in my office I was doing
various things but I feel like the
fortune long I was like I like you I
really genuinely like you as a human
being because we were the same like we
you like variety
yeah you know I expected to hear [ __ ]
devils cry and get without fire and it
was just this beautiful these beautiful
words you know in the midst of all this
gun stuff like we're we are playing loud
rock where we are I'm where I'm supposed
to be back you know in as far as loud
rock and roll goes and we we do it and
we do it right and for me to come out
with like a hard rock record in between
tours would make no sense not to me and
I wouldn't have a reason to do it this
was gonna be a book of observations it
became a album of observations and
Stewart doesn't doesn't even it's not
even the same you know
music classifications anything Guns
N'Roses does is it's off the beaten
track that's why I'm not afraid to take
the chance you know like if fans want to
come along great if some are like this
is too mellow that's fine too but I
think you've matured and you're fans of
matured I think I was 1987-88 yeah
that's a long [ __ ] journey you know
that's 32 something years no not only
did you grow you hope that they grow and
they got off the drugs like we all did
yeah I'm the seeing you guys at some
award party like I'm not seeing you live
I was watching on TV I don't know if
it's MTV or the Grammys you guys were
[ __ ] up yeah I mean [ __ ] up I was
cheering for you don't get me wrong
yes you were scaring white people like
that you were scaring people like must
have been like who the [ __ ] he had that
on had the long hair [ __ ] crazy bro
that was just Tuesday night no it's not
the same you know
specialist what's the website where they
can find the to add a ticket all of the
album from it stuff online
duck online yeah very interesting I like
the video that you put up there cool and
you have your lawyer guys getting
interviewed you really give the fan a
way to look into your mind most guys
don't give a [ __ ] about that and you
have you look beautiful
I tell you I have evolved I was watching
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame last
night
I still haven't touched Def Leppard on
that it's on HBO and I put it on I tell
you who killed with that Hall of Fame
day the cure did you watch I haven't
watched it yet the [ __ ] cure
destroyed that joint but the singer
looked like a fat woman he still had the
blue eyeshadow on he had his hair like
somebody pulled it for an hour you know
the thing about you is you've evolved
and I think slash is everybody involved
you know for years we heard Axl was done
look he came back man a great job and
then Oakland helped that ac/dc for a
little while you know and and the way he
did that was like amazing he's like you
guys don't mind I'm gonna go try out
they need it a hand here and I was like
yeah we know like bon Scott's his
all-time is like like dude you know you
don't have to really try a CDC buddy he
was really nervous I'm gonna go try out
and just see if they got a couple months
it fits in with our touring perfect and
and this last hair like hey you got the
gig but he went to Atlanta and tried out
quote-unquote and got the gig and uh
yeah he was a I saw him twice on that
tour but flew to London to see him and
flew to Cleveland to see that was he
phenomenas great phenomenal easy peasy
it's just what I think what it did for
for him you know like we got to know
Angus through that you know I guess now
come out and play with us punch times
and that was I think that thing as a
when you're 14 or 15 it when he was 14
or 15 man one day if I ever got to be in
ac/dc you know you
with a broom and he finally got to do it
amazing stuff whenever you want to come
on you have a family after the tour I
really want thank you back on the
podcast I want you to talk about what
happened on the tour and where your
feelings are that you're a bright
[ __ ] guy you're a genius you got a
family here on the church brother I
appreciate I'll be there on the 13th it
opens up with Philadelphia on the 30th
moves to DC on the 31st then you got
Boston on the first of June New York
City on the [ __ ] 30 is taking a night
off and living in LA I would write the
whole [ __ ] schedule down but I'd
rather them go yeah to your website sure
I said you're always welcome here don't
forget my dates June 1st at the Ice
House June 7th and New Orleans and June
8th at the Tabernacle theater and
Atlanta Georgia I want to thank you I
want to thank the mother [ __ ]
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank the church family for
supporting this if you're any of those
cities please support Duffy's the real
[ __ ] deal Holyfield if you have a
kickboxing school you want Duff to visit
on the road [ __ ] reach out yeah those
show up with a mouthpiece gloves and a
[ __ ] stick for you young [ __ ]
don't get any ideas
I want to thank Duff McKagan I want type
the [ __ ] and I want to thank
our sponsors for always having our back
our number one sponsor who I love with
all my heart as if recruiter why because
it listen it's hard out there it's tough
being a pimp I iron is challenging but
there's one place you can go hiring is
simple fast and smart a place where
grown businesses connect to qualified
candidates
that's zip recruited comm slash church
listen hiring used to be hard
multiple job site stacks of resumes a
confusing review process but today
hiring can be easy and you only have one
place to get it done
zip recruiter comm slash Church zip
recruit is so effective that's four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
did you hear me
the first day as applications come in
zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and invites them to apply for your job
zip recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there that's why you
gotta give zip recruiters a chance and
right now the church family can try zip
recruiter for free free free2go comm
slash Church CH you are CH that zip
recruiter dot-com slash Church zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
listen time is money
stop wasting your precious time going to
the post office when you can send
letters and packages right from your
desk I'm talking about stamps com do it
today because stamps calm is the way to
go
with just with just your computer in a
digital scale you'll be printing postage
at home boom bang you're done it's that
easy
but uncle Joey there's got to be a catch
what if I need a mail or saxophone to
timbuktu will listen with stamps calm
you can print official US postage for
any letter or any size package going
anywhere in the world that's right
anywhere in the world right from your
couch and the best part of it the
mailman will come by and pick it up they
bring the US Postal Service right to you
no more lugging boxes down to the post
office more time to get things done
you got no excuses and here's the crazy
thing about stamps calm it's actually
cheaper than the post office you never
pay full price for stamps again and
their postage meters are a fraction of
the cost plus you don't have to sign a
lease and there's no long-term
commitment how many more times they're
gonna schlep to the post office in your
life how many stop leaving money on the
table sign up today I use stamps calm my
wife uses it why because it saves us
time and money and money is precious
right now today they got a special offer
for the church family you ready our
four-week trial plus postage and a
digital scale we're gonna get that bump
huh go to stamps calm and clicking the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and use the promo code Church CH you are
CH that stamps calm and
Church listen struts in the mail like a
doctor with stamps.com I want to thank
stamps.com I want to thank zip recruiter
and I want to thank all you guys for
having our back do not forget New
Orleans six eight six seven at the
Fillmore theater and Atlanta the
Tabernacle on June 8 in Atlanta
oh and June first I got a little working
out with uncle Joey at the Ice House a
Saturday night 7:30 show you'll be out
of there tip-top Magoo by 9:00 with a
smile on your face and you go give you a
wife the stabbing that easier I know
girlfriend like I said I want to thank
all you guys for being part of our
little tape today and for supporting
this over the years I love you
[ __ ] Lee kick this
[ __ ] meal